[Music]  do you know why the Phoenix fits on the  right hand at the Emperor she is his  guardian his protector  does she suppose beautiful and strong  your job is to bring honor to the family  do you think you can do that  citizens we are under attack from  northern invaders their leader calls  himself  Horicon fight alongside of which no  survivors of his Imperial Majesty every  family must contribute one to fight a  few no son I am blessed with two  daughters I will fight  we must be strong  this time he will not return loyal brave  and true it is my duty to protect my  family  ancestors please protect her  what is your name soldier podrían  commander son of haja we're gonna make  men out of every single one of them  [Music]  the spirits is evident as something  holds you back  [Music]  when they find out who you are they will  show you no mercy  [Music]  I'm home alone I will bring honor to us  all  [Music]